But I'm fucking beyond pumped for it is Eddie Alvarez and just engage.
You just engage.
He is a fucking savage
and so's Eddie Alvarez.
Eddie Alvarez is a beast and they take a lot of people are looking past Alvarez.
You know,
Alvarez had just come off of that brutal knockout loss,
uh,
kind of a humiliating knockout loss to Conor McGregor.
And then after that he is involved in the,
the no contest,
uh,
versus um,
Dustin poor.
Yay.
I believe that was an eye poke.
That is,
I'm trying to remember how that fight went down,
but I do not,
I feel like someone got poked in the eye.
Uh,
either way it's a no contest.
So that obviously doesn't move him up the ladder or any and he's got to regroup.
Yeah,
no contest.
Here it is.
Yeah.
This was a,
okay,
now I remember what it was.
It wasn't an eye poke.
It was a knee to a downed opponent and it was a fucking phenomenal fight while
it played out against Dustin [inaudible].
They were going back and forth.
Now I remember the fight and,
um,
poor ea had Alvarez in some deep trouble.
Ann Alvarez rebounded and Alvarez I believe,
hit Dustin employ Yay.
With a knee while he was down.
Yeah,
that's exactly what happened.
And interesting.
Yeah.
See,
this is what happened.
Pour.
Yay.
Um,
yeah.
Alvarez,
you know,
Herb Dean was Safat defending it,
saying that Alvarez didn't intentionally need poor.
Yay.
And if I remember,
the fight is a crazy war.
Uh,
Alvarez had been rock pour had been robbed.
[inaudible] was bloodied and um,
Alvarez hit him with an unintentional knee,
um,
that could have resulted in a disqualification when for poor,
Yay.
And pouring.
It was saying that he looked at it as a win,
which is,
uh,
interesting.
MMM.
So anyway,
[inaudible] rebounded from that fight obviously,
and uh,
stopped Anthony Pettis in his last fight so that the division is just crazy and
unbelievably hot right now.
And everybody waiting to see what the fuck happens with Conor McGregor.
But Eddie Alvarez with the no contest.
And before that,
the Kale lost econom McGregor desperately needs a win.
And he's coming in there against one of the most fucking savage guys in the
division.
Just engaged.
You showed in that Michael Johnson fight what he's made of and a lot of people
were very excited to see him inside the octagon.
He had been fighting in the world series of fighting and looking like an
absolute monster,
but against what a lot of people thought was just not the same caliber of
competition as the UFC offered.
And so they wanted to see what would happen if he fought a real world class
fighter.
And what we saw in the Michael Johnson fight,
it's adjusting gage,
he who fights,
uh,
I don't want to say reckless,
but he puts himself in danger and it's one of the things that makes him so
excited and he forces his will on people.
He's a ferocious striker and a,
an excellent wrestler as well,
and just fucking puts it on fighters.
He tests there will,
he puts tremendous pressure on fighters.
And the,
the fight with Michael Johnson was just a pleasure to watch,
just so much fun and so fucking crazy.
There was so much chaos in that fight.
And a lot of people were introduced to just engage you from that fight.
The hardcore fans had known him already from the world series of fighting and
had heard about him through the Internet.
But the UFC fans and uh,
the people that were watching that night,
they really got a chance to be treated too.
Does the kind of chaotic fight that is really going to bring like the casual fan
when they see a guy like just engage you fight.
It's really gonna make you a fan of this kid.
Just his style is just,
there's very few guys,
I mean other than,
I mean Matt Brown who I talked about before,
but even Matt Brown is capable of winning so many different ways where as Gagey
he's gonna probably try to knock you out or get,
I mean,
he's even said himself that he might get knocked out.
You're probably going to see me get knocked out.
He said,
uh,
over the next few years he's got that mindset,
this kill or be killed mindset.
And,
uh,
it's just absolutely fascinating to see this kid compete inside the octagon
because he's so fucking crazy because he's such a fucking animal inside the
octagon.
He just got this,
uh,
undeniable killer instinct and indomitable spirit.
And she's,
there's levels to this game.
There's levels physically,
and he's at a very high level physically,
but there's also levels mentally.
And that's what excites me about Justi Iag is,
is the,
the mental level.
He just has zero quit in him and he's 100% ferocious.
So him fighting a fucking animal like Eddie Alvarez,
that's just a recipe for a good time.
And we're going to get to see that.
And we're going to get to see that next Saturday night live on paper view.